director Comey's firing by President
Trump led to Muller's appointment as
special counsel James Comey is with us
for his first television interview since
the Moller report was released to the
public his memoir a higher loyalty truth
lies and leadership has just come out in
paperwork the paperback rather James
Comey good morning good to have you here
I'm really interested to hear your take
on them the Muller report we saw that
the special counsel in that report
detailed ten instances of possible
obstruction of justice by the president
why do you think the special counsel
ultimately decided not to charge him
with obstruction of justice I think
because he was trying to be both
principled and fair he was trying to
abide the Department of Justice ruling
that says you can't indict a sitting
president and reasoned that if I can't
indict a sitting president I ought not
to accuse him of a crime because that
wouldn't be fair given that I can't
clear him I'll just lay out the evidence
for a future prosecutor and for Congress
but one of the things you said in your
book is that you believe you're firing
was potentially obstruction of justice
and the Special Counsel didn't go that
far right he just collected the evidence
which if you read it and I hope folks
will actually read it is deeply
concerning but he decided not to make
the call because he thought that
wouldn't be a fair thing to do so I'll
just compile it all and what he compiled
is really concerning especially when you
look at the 10 episodes together one of
the things the Attorney General points
to in those 10 episodes is that there
was kind of an initiating event that put
the president's mindset in what sense
intent is important the president
thought there there this is gonna mess
up my administration and one of the
things Barr focused on was your
reluctance to tell the public that the
president was not actually under
investigation the president not having
you not tell the public felt like oh my
gosh this is all stacked against me and
that that was kind of the initiating
thing that made him so paranoid yeah I
heard the Attorney General say that and
I don't think it's a fair summary of the
evidence the evidence that maybe his
motive but a whole lot of people commit
crimes in this country because they're
frustrated and they're angry that isn't
the question the question is when he did
the things he did was he intending to
obstruct justice he may have a motive to
push something away that embarrasses him
or irritates him that's actually not the
key question
have you been surprised by bill bar
summary letter yes what surprised you
that it struck me especially after I
read the Muller report as misleading I'm
not suggesting it was intentionally
misleading but it was inadequate to
summarize that work what was misleading
about what the Attorney General said
well it certainly gave the impression
that Bob Muller had decided that he was
not going to rule on this question of
obstruction of justice when that's not
what Muller did Muller laid it out and
signaled to a future prosecutor after
this individuals out of office you ought
to take a serious look at charging him
you know the Republicans have said case
closed time to move on here you think do
they have a point well I think they have
a point in the sense that the American
people now have a clear view of how the
president acted read the report if you
didn't have a clear enough view of
Donald Trump's character and the way he
approaches this office you now do it's
time to move on to the most important
thing we do which is vote to decide who
should represent us as president of the
United States Attorney General says he
believes spying occurred in looking
after the president's then campaign what
do you think about that you have no idea
what he's talking about the FBI doesn't
spy the FBI investigates we investigated
a very serious allegation that Americans
might be hooked up with the Russian
effort to attack our democracy the
Republicans need to breathe into a paper
bag if if we had confronted the same
facts with a different candidate say a
Democrat candidate where one of their
advisers was talking to a foreign
adversaries representative about that
adversaries interference in our election
they would be screaming for the FBI to
investigate and that's all we did so the
debate is a semantic one the FBI was
investigating into the Trump campaign
but you're saying they had cause to and
you just wouldn't use the word spot of
course and just people just ought to
look at the predication for the opening
of that investigation we should have
been fired if we didn't investigate this
but you have tens of thousands of FBI
agents on the front lines every day
doing work to protect America to keep
this country safe and when the Attorney
General undermines the integrity of
those agents by suggesting they're
involved in spying against a president
what does that do to the reputation
yeah it's deeply concerning because
ordinary folks will accept what the
president says what the Attorney General
says and that
hurts our ability to be trusted as FBI
agents in courtrooms and at doorways so
it's a very bad thing you know we were
talking about the op-ed that you wrote
just just a couple weeks ago and I
encourage back and read it yeah again
Nora because you you essentially go
through you say how could mr. Barr a
bright an accomplished lawyer start
saying these things you talked about rod
Rosenstein and then you say what
happened to these people and they said
more often proximity to an amoral leader
reveals something depressing mr. Trump
eats your soul in small bites no and I'd
like to add to that it starts with your
sitting silent while he lies both in
public and private making you complicit
by your silence in meetings with him is
assertions about what everyone thinks
and what is obviously true wash over you
unchallenged I'm curious to know his
question were you at home mad one day
and just say I have to say something we
didn't know I wasn't mad I was actually
kind of depressed watching people of
accomplishment very bright people act in
ways that are shocking the Deputy
Attorney General of the United States
quoting approvingly Donald Trump on the
importance of the rule of law really and
so a lot of folks were asking me what
happened to these people and I don't
know for sure but I've seen it up close
from four months of working near Donald
Trump and I've seen him wrap people in
this web of deception and delusion and
I've seen it shape them I've seen some
great people stand up to it but others
that happens how do you believe he wraps
people in a web of deception well first
of all when you sit with him he'll just
tell lies where he's not asking for your
your reaction to it he'll just talk
about how he had the largest inaugural
crowd in history much larger than Barack
Obama's and if you don't jump in and
interrupt and contradict the president
you feel like you've kind of agreed with
him and these lies wash over you over
and over again then the next step is you
sit at a cabinet meeting and everybody
praises the leader and then the next
thing you know he's attacking the
institution you represent someone like
Bill Barr always said the Attorney
General has to stand up for special
prosecutors and suddenly you're not
doing that and you find yourself trapped
if you do point out that the defense
secretary mattis did not do that who
knows he was one of the exceptions in
that room right I said a moral leaders
tend to reveal character in the case of
Jim mattis or
sterling character the former FBI
assistant director of intelligence Kevin
Brock turns your phrase around on you oh
and he wrote he himself ate away at the
sole the FBI not in small bites but in
dangerously large ones reaction to that
talk to people inside the FBI and
they'll be better able to evaluate what
I do I wonder about that too John do you
feel in some level that your credibility
has been hurt because Democrats and
Republicans have criticized some of your
actions and decisions definitely yeah
definitely yeah sure just read what I
write listen to what I say and evaluate
it how are my facts what is my reasoning
seem like to you if you don't like it if
my facts are wrong don't listen to me I
don't think they are though I thought
maybe we just end on because you have a
new preface in in your book in which you
say that you sort of pose the question
are we gonna be okay yes what's the
answer to that yes because American
history shows us that we always have
periods of retreat and pain after
periods of tremendous progress and we
recover because there's a ballast in
America and that's our values the great
middle of America represents our values
and they stir every so often and I hope
they're stirring now I see signs of it
and are gonna vote their values yes back
to what you said about the facts it's
been said you're entitled to your own
opinion you're not entitled to your
facts and to your point read the report
and look at the fact the truth is a real
thing yes it is a real thing thank you
James Comey always good to see you great
to have you at the table
thank you the paperback version of
commis book a higher loyalty truth lies
and friendship is available now wherever
you'd like to buy your books got lots
options